how's it going bros my name is Peter Pan
we're playing uncharted 4 this game is
so [ __ ] cool let's keep going
oh well okay just change time ow
so I start my fuzzy little gets better
estaba you're gonna have to do better
man got a MOS con esta let's go ah
cabanas no I stopped let's go
let's go [ __ ] the scalper pass a skull
how do I block the skull register Oh
what the [ __ ] was that the [ __ ] are you
talking about me mama said it to me
close up oh nice - that's right
ah [ __ ] slap teach you how to play the
controls dude I will a minute is this
what did you say about my dog Edgar is a
beautiful woman [ __ ] you come here
oh [ __ ] no well I'm dead how you could
have broken my arm due to noise she get
the little
so let go yeah [ __ ] I don't know what
Oh God oh [ __ ] man mucho another one oh
[ __ ] with a smart you asked for it
getcha now huh huh this is so [ __ ]
frustrating another another one [ __ ]
teach elders minutes
come on come on what repeat what skin oh
oh you got [ __ ] you call me gringo the
[ __ ] you thought you even know you talk
[ __ ] I've been so bad [ __ ] Oh mud fight
huh no I would like to not die for me
come on Oh
my turn
this is for Edgar oh come on man we
weren't fighting
oh right little guy we're my dad here
you go come here that hey give me a car
when you're tall enough to ride the
rides tequila por el culo solitaire ah
Oh Carlo he made fun of men can I sure
got him man I shipped them so much so
just me
all behind you how long am I supposed to
be in here huh where's the toilet you
looking at it have fun
I will I will have fun yes I'll just
[ __ ] my pants then [ __ ] you
while that kind of suck
get up
okay IRAs having a great dream - hey hey
all right easy
ah okay get clean oh all right
God Almighty I'm living this is me
infernal place this so yeah I'd like to
take a shower
got you people candidate dings morning
boys
or is it evening uh it's hard to tell
down here working you wanna get up the
stairs now I was gonna take alligator
sorry I'm so I'm so sorry
good to stretch the legs a little bit
you know feels nice hey nice to see you
morning exercise right humid ah welcome
to Panama hey gringo v lo que hiciste a
Gustavo tengoku nombre I mean I [ __ ]
your mom a Varga cuando regressive
Tejano de nosotros nothing car gamble
they don't like me women see Keaton
cigar oh nice Hey
Thank You Lee something looks like you
have some fans yeah my adoring public
why are we here Panama Hummer pop have
it open
yes everyone is bald here what the [ __ ]
must be the Sun
lisara sorry little yes es una sorpresa
deviated that day you speak a little
spin laughing wait what did you say haha
oh [ __ ]
trusty uh-oh hi fellow gentleman I was
just on my way to the cafeteria nos in
wires Spanish people such [ __ ] are
they Spanish um Brazilian no one Swedish
okay taking me anyway you'll see yours I
always wanted to say that they taking me
to you Oh hahaha no no not that way um
you okay thank you
what a gentleman yeah don't bore me
sketchy at all hey you know this doesn't
look like the warden's office go go left
okay Manik yeah yeah there we sorry I
didn't catch that
oh yeah what is this dude are we taking
me out on a date all right okay take
these cuffs off or what i won in you
know whatever you hope to find out there
i won in
my Vargas the deal was just to get us in
and out of here that's it just I'm
sticking my neck out for you jingles
yeah and Rafe is paying you a lot of
money for your trouble
see but not nearly enough you were told
not to open that yes I was also told out
to take bribes not to bring it on here
and I beat on my teammates but here we
are just be careful with that it's 300
years old I was a member of Captain
Henry
Avery's group you know that ha ha he was
a pirate the pirate who pulled off the
biggest heist in history you got away
with it
I looked amongst great over 100 million
dollars worth of gold and jewels or
through one single ship that guns way
yeah I'm familiar with the story can you
get to the point uh-huh I Oh could hide
the highest cell in this piñas prison
not here I hope someday you will find
your way into this infernal place bear
my cross and discover the riches of
paradise ah now we just need Nicolas
Cage and won't get there the riches of
paradise it's a metaphor no no no no no
you have friends did not pay to get into
this infernal place in search of a
metaphor i won in right okay i won
let me go up there check out the prison
cell if there's still anything there
after 300 years you can take this up
with Rafe come on
we're gonna climb I think it looks
awesome so excited port for water are
you gonna get up there anyways climb Oh
unless of course you want to do it since
you want in and all just don't break
your neck yeah it's so good drama
interesting guy yeah it it just over
there under the word table by the crates
great thanks where'd by the crates on
the work table oh okay there yeah how
the [ __ ] did he get here though honestly
um while I'm stuck already uh could you
help me ice no I love the bushes they're
so sexy listen I can be a man and find
bushes to be sick oh hello
sliding time Hey yeah yeah yo Missy cake
yeah there it is
whoa let's not go down there yet by the
crates you said that were my equipment
is bingo now we're in business and a
beer got our breakfast dude you probably
haven't eaten in a while if you're stuck
in that cell dude I think she might do
the trick
what is this whoa hi I'm that was what
was that that was not me
nailed it adios amigo that son of a
bitch's neck look at this look at the
ocean it looks [ __ ] incredible dude
man I can't wait from four when I'm old
like [ __ ] 70
just imagine the video games man just
imagine this video games if this is what
we're looking at now there's the prison
so how do I get up there being retired
is gonna be [ __ ] awesome
can you imagine but that sounds
depressing all right I get him
but really it's me whoo in a row [ __ ]
yeah I hope someone saw that cuz that
was [ __ ] cool yeah nailing chilling
chilling at 11:00 I bet have a better
better better dude I want to swim so bad
how did we know that was there we didn't
but pocket videogames
let's go to the other side climb around
it's [ __ ] awesome
okay I suppose we go up oh I'm fine
just want everyone to know I'm fine
where did we go within down I suppose no
that's a terrible idea
Eris what are you doing Nate I'm alright
there you go buddy
yeah he's so cute hey hey
nail day huh looks like I can slide down
there hook on that post probably are you
crazy
I gotta say it is an honor to be playing
this game right now for you breasts just
look at this
[ __ ] beautiful this is art I'm so
[ __ ] amazed by how this looks like so
cool all right here we go okay G hook it
real good
whoa Oh something till sam hears about
this
Sam Sam
onward and upward wish I could see a
shark or sums I feel like I can smell it
you know I hope you boys are watching on
poultry you can take in what I'm seeing
my beautiful face in high resolution you
know what I mean all right
we knew good knew where to go up let me
go up there it is cool huh
that does not look safe dude nothing
about this game makes sense let me feel
safe oh god the heights man I can't do
it Oh God all right how about yeah I
gotta find the highest self no these
burns in a nice view before he was
executed
uh-huh
so they put people high up in cells
before we keep them trap does that make
sense I don't know what I'm talking
about okay we're almost we're dropping
down here I think we are whoo oh stop
doing that Nate you're gonna get mom up
it's a heart attack hard to believe
there were dozens of pirates holed up in
here just waiting to be hanged okay
we're - sounds like a good pirate hang
am i right please subscribe for more
quality of content all right here we go
there's something I just his letter -
you're hanging around for 300 modern
Prison was bad interesting my hand looks
so good it's kind of hand I want to kiss
you know when you see it just me [ __ ]
you alright [ __ ] you it feels low-key
like I'm playing Last of Us again which
is very nice the game was [ __ ]
awesome I love that game
we found a treasure and stairs huts
du hast ain't off a mountain thank you
Michael
thank you am I not supposed to go up
there another way okay now I can hold
and hold row eight eight eight eight
yeah [ __ ] cheap Chinese [ __ ] why did
I do that again try another one perhaps
maybe try the metal gate no um okay okay
I got it
my bad I'm sorry rain fart happens come
on cut me some slack
I don't know what's like ass but cut me
I barely believe this place is still
standing yeah you are Tang Shi are you
how to build a sturdy prison you just
said it's barely falling hurt really
alright not gonna lie this is pretty
awesome
[ __ ] you
whoa they actually built a prison like
that is this is prison exist ah no I
can't we got here my god sorry I'm sorry
I know it gets annoying but I'm not a
dog man I love him and Sam's missing out
here we go
burns his cell how do we know this is
burns cell we're like a sweet okay we're
yeah it's actually really pretty
are those like Greek all these squiggles
and scratches must mean something
squiggles and scragga 'ls are we
technically locked in a moon alchemy
symbols for gold and silver wait a sec I
saw something like this on the letter
yeah chime well that's part of the
symbol uh there's the other half now
then
yeah that's more like it
okay got a zodiac symbol Sagittarius and
the Scorpio sign okay
Sagittarius there's that one which is 10
and the Scorpio sign is that the other
one is this one right
ten and two twelve right
it's an M that's me yeah okay so i press
i press the stone that's 12 okay cool
this one now that's not dude Nate cuz
one either
yeah it isn't because that's not the one
I can to Sun X and I I alright alright
classes yet nice abs do
I really feel like I'm a treasure hunter
right numbers I don't know am i spring
ipad hire - sorry I don't
oh god don't just put your arm and dude
my number one fear I guess this is in
time head back which way'd oh hello the
gate was open on the lawn gotta watch
that first step
what the [ __ ] designed this door what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah whoa [ __ ] yeah I'm
naked
ah uh hold and used to rebel down we go
move yeah yeah huh no what we swing
bigger ah ah oh that's awesome dude
[ __ ] yeah are you enjoying this so far I
hope it's fun to watch as it is to play
I feel bad you want to play don't play
obey ever fine oh Jesus he doesn't even
I goes my shoulder he goes to be shown
hard arse
they are freaking cannons on no that's
that'd be stupid
our three elders Vargas I want a cut I
want in
my dick in you am i right haha I'm sorry
I want to cut all right little racist
impression their native no no problem
mate you just got this [ __ ] made it
nailed it look I don't want this part
any kiss is so gorgeous but did we did
get what we came for
umm single boring second in this game so
far [ __ ] love it now we're talking it
bothers me a little bit that you don't
run before you jump you know what I mean
it seems like it Canada's a little
stroll if I did it you'd be sure I
[ __ ] press too drunk should we drop
down on his face on his bald face yeah
[ __ ] you made it no I couldn't find I
couldn't find anything you know break
just a letter I stuck the cross of my
ass place was picked clean
there's a clue hidden up there somewhere
I couldn't find it are you sure were you
looking in the right place maybe I just
missed something in the letter it could
have been another tower that collapsed
centuries ago yeah what a [ __ ] idiot
there any plants of this place you know
like blueprints oh could be there's a
bunch of old files okay great great good
go look through those okay see what you
can dig up
meanwhile I'll talk to Sam he's our
Avery expert
maybe he can make sense of this whole
mess right I looked through the files
yeah turn around
I don't like this that was too easy man
I was too easy
you don't talking to him come and find
me
you guys can go if I catch you fighting
one more time while we can the whole for
you sacrifice just like I did
[ __ ] give Adam ups mine oh I feel like
nate is me I must learn handsome fellow
siento see cosas que la la noon Tavis
cuando Talia Nando parity he's lastly
virtuoso girl you all right yeah just
another day at the office
come on hey whoa whoa yeah Leah keep me
in suspense are you
you were right no we were right now you
just got a fine race on race oh don't
start please come on like you said we
did this you and me now this rich
[ __ ] comes in on the tail end how
long we've been trying to get in here
we had some leads no we didn't hey not
one so like it or not no race no Vargas
and no getting in here
speaking of Vargas like me to get a
problem what kind of problem did he let
you under the old prison yeah yeah he
did one after he read the letter that
guy is bad news so how much doesn't know
enough that he wants a cut [ __ ] Rafe if
anybody else finds out about this I'll
work it out with Vargas don't sweat it
right now let's just get off the more
important match let's find somewhere a
little more private
how are we gonna get out of the jail is
what I mag concerned about you know all
right coast is clear
okay so what do we got oh [ __ ] hey may I
just be careful okay
would with gold and silver inlay it's
well-made it's hollow why would one of
Avery's men go through the trouble of
hiding a cheap crucifix it's not a
crucifix technically a crucifix is
rubies there was some please inside the
hollow cross it's not Jesus
well you're right there's no crown of
thorns he's tied to the cross well if
it's not Jesus read the inscription
digna factus Kipnis we receive we
receive the due reward of our deeds okay
as a benefit of growing up in a Catholic
orphanage that's st. Dismas penitent
thief what's the connection guys let's
just pretend I skipped all of Sunday
school okay during the crucifixion Jesus
is placed between two thieves okay
one of them mocked Jesus the other one
this guy was penitent he accepted his
punishment with grace and Jesus brought
him to paradise I've never heard a
penitent thief if they what
you figured it out there is a cathedral
of st. Dismas
in Scotland the last second cause this
is Scotland it can't be a coincidence
you know I had my doubts about you -
that's fine Vargas get the hell out of
the show
uh-oh let me guess this is the guy you
picked a fight with ah no yet so many
friends dije que no hemos terminado mira
los que nós de que contar elmer hablar g
no salad you know why do not omit us
okay oh oh it's a fight its own oh no no
no I got this move yeah what the [ __ ]
he's going up you're punching the dick
pigs and I eat garbage you belong in the
trash you're trash you're all trash [ __ ]
you [ __ ] your mom I [ __ ] your balls face
up their daughter on it and then I rub
my ass on it what yeah you missed me
yeah great seeing that you move good old
man for now oh you got bud dad dad
strike Oh
headbutt me
oh oh that's gonna hurt you tell me that
[ __ ] those gorgeous
tell me [ __ ] don't you dare
punch guys let's make this [ __ ]
school and get out of here really cool
fighting you Hey
very realistic um come on no oh you
found an old trick oh god don't break
man thank you oh I love that way that
worked out well that move again for the
[ __ ] million time
oh god I'm [ __ ] dying dude no sucking
clothes Oh Oh No get off ya basta habla
a lien MAHS mrs. de Clare quilty las
reglas I leave you answers anyone else
want to break the rules you think soon
guess it's all right my mummy mohombi oh
he no real ID now are you bringing in
contraband for your sniper thing who do
you think you are ya know so says de los
Gringos hey Murphy Cena
daija knows
dang nose
he's gonna be pretty pissed about this
yeah
took you long enough we almost got
killed you know you still might uh-oh
Vargas seriously oh I didn't find
anything must be in a different Tower
well how can I say I was raised Catholic
I always carry one funny hey hey look
it's worthless
all right you think I'm an idiot okay
you want to renegotiate fine stop acting
like a third-world thug guess where we
are what they gone away thank you
we're willing to give you 10% think half
we're doing most of the work 20 and
you'd never find it without us 25 equals
25 that sound fair guys I suppose I can
live with that
yeah sure yeah before hundred billion
divides nicely by four looks like we
have a deal yes we have a deal
now let's kiss and if you ever cross me
oh Jesus that's that are you out of your
goddamn mind you want to find out guys
what are we doing here sticking to the
plan was this part of the plan spawn Oh
God meesa maama oh [ __ ] god damn it ray
we're gonna end that episode there okay
Bruce I'm gonna end part two here I'm
gonna keep the videos a little longer if
you bros want it let me know and I'm
just so pumped for more I will see you
in the new episode tomorrow if you
promise me to leave a like and a comment
and that's it bro say awesome
did I break them Jesus Christ throw them
at you I'll put it on the safety strap
there's a stupid teddy bear just look at
the lights Hickory was oh yeah